The farm animals were standing on a hill.
Goat said.
Look at that little barn on the other hill.
I think I will go to the barn.
said Goat.
Goat ran down the hill and across a field.
Oh no, Goat is shrinking.
said Cow.
Goat ran farther.
Goodness me, Goat is shrinking more.
said Cow.
Goat ran even farther.
Oh no, now Goat has disappeared.
said Cow.
I will fly to the barn to find Goat.
said Duck.
Duck began to fly to the barn.
Oh no, Duck is shrinking, too.
said Cow.
Duck flew farther.
Oh no, now Duck has disappeared.
said Cow.
I will run to the barn and find Goat and Duck.
said Pig.
Pig ran to the barn.
Oh no, Pig is shrinking, too.
said Cow.
Pig ran farther and farther.
Goodness me, now Pig has disappeared.
said Cow.
I'd better go find Pig, Duck, and Goat.
she said.
Cow began to run toward the barn.
She ran down the hill.
The barn began to get bigger.
Cow ran across the field.
The barn became bigger and bigger.
Cow reached the barn.
She could see it was a very big barn.
She saw Pig, Duck, and Goat.
They had not disappeared!